no sé si habéis estado alguna vez en un
impreso es un divertido espectáculo
donde el público lanza palabras al azar
y un actor tiene que recogerlas e
intentar construir una historia para
encadenar las pues bien no va a ser
exactamente lo mismo pero lo que vamos a
ver ahora es algo parecido porque lo que
tengo que hacer es conectar dos palabras
capitalismo y consciencia que no solo
suenan como un oxímoron cuando las
juntas sino que además prácticamente
nadie sabe lo que significan por
separado así que vamos allá
esta es la constelación de palabras
aparentemente inconexas que voy a
intentar conectar para darle sentido al
título de esta charla
antes me gustaría hacer una pequeña
aclaración me gustaría que esta charla
fuera una humilde invitación a abrir
nuestra mente y contemplar la vida desde
una perspectiva totalmente diferente a
la que estamos acostumbrados todos
conocemos la perspectiva científica de
la vida según la cual la vida es el
resultado de un largo proceso evolutivo
conducido por el azar y por lo tanto
estúpido que milagrosamente condujo las
partículas estelares que surgieron del
big-bang a lo que somos nosotros hoy en
día bien la a mí me gustaría poner
encima la mesa una perspectiva diferente
que sería la de que la vida a lo mejor
sólo quizás es un proceso
extraordinariamente inteligente que nace
con el big-bang y del cual nosotros sólo
somos una muy pequeña y posiblemente
insignificante parte
dicho esto a simplemente recordar que
esto es como decía al principio una
humilde invitación a contemplar durante
breves minutos abrir la mente contemplar
durante breves minutos ésta
la provocadora perspectiva
un aviso también no sé si algún
científico en la sala pero si lo hay
esta sería una fantástica oportunidad
para salir corriendo
no veo a nadie salir así que vamos a
empezar
nuestra historia empieza hace
aproximadamente 4.500 millones de años
cuando en la tierra sucedió un efecto un
algo singular de la nada aparecieron
unos diminutos saquitos de citoplasma
con adn en su interior la ciencia no
sabe muy bien de dónde surgieron estos
taquitos de hecho
no tienen ni idea de dónde de dónde
surgieron y de hecho lo curioso es que
normalmente lo habitual es que los
padres sean los que bautizan a sus hijos
pero lo que ha hecho la ciencia es lo
contrario es decir nosotros los
descendientes de los saquitos hemos
llamado a los saquitos células
procariotas y a lo que dieron lugar con
su aparición le hemos llamado vida
pero lo curioso lo que es lo que decía
antes nadie sabe de dónde salieron no
tenemos ni idea y por si esa queda algún
científico en la sala
me gustaría que tras matizar un poco
estas palabras cuando digo que no
tenemos ni idea lo que quiero decir es
que la ciencia no tiene ni puñetera idea
de dónde salieron los taquitos el
citoplasma y mucho menos todavía el adn
que contenían lo que sí sabemos es que
desde su aparición la vida no ha hecho
más que progresar en una sorprendente
dirección la de una complejidad cada vez
mayor y esa esta capacidad de progresar
siempre hacia una mayor complejidad de
la vida a lo que nosotros llamamos
evolución las células procariotas en
particular no son muy inteligentes de
hecho se pasaron como dos mil millones
de años sin hacer prácticamente nada
simplemente se dedicarán a reproducirse
lo cual tampoco está mal pero
no es precisamente un acto de
inteligencia o quizá si el caso es que
después de 2000 años
reproduciéndose como conejos dos células
decidieron hacer algo realmente
sorprendente
decidieron ponerse de acuerdo para
ayudarse mutuamente
con el fin de maximizar sus
posibilidades de supervivencia porque lo
hiciera como es posible para la ciencia
para esto sí que tiene una explicación
razonable que es que no tenemos ni
puñetera idea de por qué dos células
descerebradas se ponen de acuerdo para
colaborar y maximizar así sus
posibilidades de supervivencia de nuevo
el azar
bien el problema es que las células no
se contentaron con esto y siguieron
haciendo cosas raras del yo te ayudo a
ti y tú me ayudas a mí al cabo de un
tiempo pasaron yo me encargo de esto y
tuve encargas de aquello
había nacido la especialización supongo
que estas alturas ya no hace falta que
explique la fantástica teoría que la
tiene la ciencia tiene al respecto de
cómo pudo suceder algo así no abra
cadabra
bien las células no son muy muy
inteligentes pero aunque lo fueran yo
creo que una célula procariotas ni en
sus más húmedos sueños tendría la
capacidad de imaginarse lo que aquellos
primeros actos asociativos dieron lugar
cuando nos miramos al espejo no somos
conscientes de lo que estamos viendo lo
que estamos viendo realmente es una
increíble una monumental comunidad
celular de 30 mil millones de miembros
que asombrosamente tienen la capacidad
de ponerse de pie coordinarse para
caminar pensar lo que es más
impresionante ser conscientes de sí
mismas
en la escuela a todos nos han enseñado
que la principal mecanismo evolutivo de
la vida se llama
y competitividad
pero viendo esto yo le llamo
colaboración
bien el caso es que la colaboración no
ha parado de evolucionar a lo largo de
la vida las comunidades celulares
enormes comunidades celulares que
integran la naturaleza han seguido
colaborando y
innovando en cuanto a formas de
colaboración se refiere primero fue la
simbiosis luego fue la compartición y
finalmente una especie una sólo una
especie descubrió una forma de colaborar
que ninguna otra especie ha sido capaz
de desarrollar esta forma de colaborar
se llama intercambio y es tan grande la
ventaja competitiva que nos otorga que
no solamente ha creado a diferencias
insalvables entre nuestra especie y el
resto sino que además ha creado
diferencias insalvables prácticamente
dentro de nuestra propia especie el
primero que observé esto fue adam smith
en 1776 smith se escribió un libro la
riqueza de las naciones en el cual
explicaba por qué unas naciones son
ricas y otras son pobres básicamente lo
que decía es me dices que la razón por
la que unas son ricas y otras son
porque unas han sido mucho más
inteligentes o son mucho más eficientes
a la hora de mucho más gente genes que
las otras a la hora de utilizar la
principal herramienta de intercambio que
el ser humano ha ideado jamás esta
herramienta se llama mercado
el problema es que smith nunca le puso
nombre a su descubrimiento y en cambio
quien sí lo hizo fue marx donde smith
observaba una herramienta realmente
eficiente para intercambiar bienes y
servicios a través del dinero marx veía
unos buitres que utilizaban esa
herramienta del mercado para transformar
dinero en más dinero y es evidente que
cuando marx después de observar esto
pues la intención con la que marx acuñó
el término capitalismo pues obviamente
no era la de crear un club de fans
verdad pero al mismo tiempo es
importante ser conscientes que lo que
marx había observado o había definido
con capitalismo no era un sistema como
tal marx describió la forma la forma
negativa
el mal uso que muchos estaban haciendo
de ese sistema
en el fondo marx estaba siendo
probablemente víctima de la misma visión
antropocéntrica que todos padecemos
debido a nuestra limitada perspectiva
nuestra vida es tan extremadamente corta
que no somos capaces de ver más allá de
lo que tenemos delante de las narices no
somos capaces de ver la totalidad de lo
que está sucediendo es aquello que los
árboles no nos dejan ver el bosque lo
que marx observo a escala humana es lo
que nosotros podríamos ver la escala
celular si fuéramos capaces de ver a
cámara rápida los aquellos primeros
intentos de colaboración celular
seguramente no fue fácil debió haber
muchos intentos fallidos pero al final
algunos triunfaron y fueron aquellos
pequeños triunfos los que crearon
comunidades celulares enormemente
prósperas para su época que hoy
posiblemente posiblemente no forman
parte del registro fósil de la
naturaleza pero como digo en su momento
esas comunidades fueron muy prósperas y
sembraron la semilla de lo que somos hoy
en día de la misma forma lo que marx
observó como torpes formas de utilizar
el mercado como herramienta de
intercambio eso que llamó el capitalismo
muchas de esas formas de utilizar el
mercado torpemente hoy en día forman
parte del registro fósil de las
organizaciones empresariales pero no hay
que olvidar que fueron esas torpes
formas las que nos sacaron de la edad
media y crearon siglos de prosperidad
sin precedentes en nuestra historia no
nos vamos a engañar la prosperidad ha
venido acompañada de agujeros de ozono
de calentamiento global
maltrato animal y maltrato infantil
explotación infantil extinción de
especies guerras sin sentido y un sinfín
de calamidades que de hecho convierten
en curioso o irónico que nosotros
llamemos azar a lo que dio origen a la
vida y calificamos la inteligencia lo
que hemos hecho de ella pero a la gran
pregunta al final es
somos realmente una amenaza para la vida
o lo que somos es una amenaza para
nosotros mismos y para todo lo que ahora
en el momento actual nos rodea la vida
desde una perspectiva amplia nos damos
nos y nos tenemos esta perspectiva
antropocéntrica lo que podemos ver es
que
no hay nada que le podamos hacer a la
vida o la tierra a nuestro planeta que
devuelva el planeta al estadio en que se
encontraba hace digamos cinco mil
millones de años cuando era un mar de
lava y ni siquiera existía el adn está
la vida realmente no nos necesita esto
que nosotros llamamos destruir el
planeta no es nada
que la naturaleza no pueda solucionar en
cien mil doscientos mil si queréis un
millón de años total un suspiro la
escala cosmológica ampliemos de nuevo
nuestra perspectiva y miremos a lo que
está sucediendo y desde esta perspectiva
más amplia a la que os invito a adoptar
lo que se está viendo hoy es que están
emergiendo una nueva generación de
organizaciones hoy hemos visto bastantes
de ellas por cierto que de hecho el
mismo ted es una de ellas pero prohíbe
podríamos citar muchas más con y sin
ánimo de lucro como la luz como twitter
como open arms como wikipedia
que para ellas su propósito en la vida
no es ganar dinero sino que contemplan
el dinero como el oxígeno que les
permite desarrollar su propósito en la
vida
y esto es un cambio de coordenadas
fundamental para estas organizaciones el
concepto de ánimo de lucro es tan
estúpido como para un ser vivo el
concepto de ánimo de oxígeno y lo
interesante es que cuando estas
organizaciones dan este paso en
dirección del propósito superior se
desarrolla automáticamente en ellas unos
valores de una cultura corporativa mucho
más colaborativas no es que la
competitividad quede atrás sino que la
competitividad va pasando lentamente a
un segundo plano y la colaboración va
pasando al primer plano y a medida que
más y más organizaciones dan este paso
es la economía globalmente considerada
la que lo da también y de hecho lo que
está sucediendo hoy en día es que se
está produciendo un significativo cambio
de coordenadas en nuestro sistema
económico capitalista tradicional
estamos pasando de un viejo sistema de
coordenadas dominado por los ejes de
ánimo de lucro y de la competitividad a
un nuevo sistema de coordenadas dominado
por los ejes del propósito superior y de
la colaboración
en el momento que esto sucede sucede una
singularidad muy habitual en la
naturaleza y es que entra en
funcionamiento esto que llamamos
selección natural lo que vamos a ver en
los próximos años si la naturaleza no
cambia su criterio evolutivo cosa que
teniendo en cuenta que en los 4.500
millones de años últimos no ha pasado lo
que vamos a ver decía es como las
organizaciones que mejor compiten son
justamente las que mejor colaboran y
esto que suena como un oxímoron en
realidad va a tener fatales
consecuencias para algunos en particular
para aquellos que todavía forman parte
del viejo sistema de coordenadas lo que
vamos a ver en los próximos años es como
esta vieja guardia del capitalismo se
dirige ella solita hacia su propia
eutanasia y lo curioso lo irónico lo
irónico es que van a ser las mismas
fuerzas del mercado que los encumbraron
a la cima los que ahora los van a
empujar al abismo
debes ser consciente el capitalismo si
consideramos la vida desde la
perspectiva de este largo proceso
colaborativo que nos ha traído hasta
aquí lo que veremos es que este mismo
proceso está creando un nuevo tipo de
comunidades celulares
estas nuevas comunidades se llaman
organizaciones lo de ánimo de lucro y ha
quedado obsoleto y sus células somos
nosotros el futuro de la humanidad
depende de la velocidad a la que estas
nuevas organizaciones o comunidades sean
capaces
colaborar más y más eficientemente
porque nos estamos quedando sin tiempo y
no tenemos un planeta
el capitalismo amigos míos será
consciente o no será muchas gracias
[Aplausos]